it's time for the summer break but Sgt
us a microbiology student from Istanbul
isn't heading to the beach she's on her
way to a political meeting her route
takes her across Taksim Square in the
past few weeks she was confronted by
water cannon and pepper spray here but
the 21 year old doesn't fear the
hundreds of police who still fill the
square and the neighboring daisy park
esky isn't bitter she says the struggle
for democracy is about more than just
the park janna bicornis on it's about
restrictions on the sale of alcohol it's
the government's campaign against
abortion and women's rights and the
introduction of tuition fees for
students and also that turkey should
keep out of the war in Syria s key and
her friends are working together to help
students who were arrested and
mistreated during the protests they're
searching for video evidence online and
have organized free legal aid young
people like them aren't interested in
the beliefs and various political
movements of the older generation they
want to take part in politics but remain
independent people understand that
democracy is more than just elections
Parliament's and political parties
there's a democracy from below that's
what we want to practice we're not the
new Turkish people but a new youth
washing over the country like a wave I'm
certain that even more people will join
this movement in the near future
knowledge in general
esky is always looking for people to
discuss the democracy movement with
whether it's the older generation or
even opponents and skeptics this
pensioner tells her to go on protesting
but without resorting to violence he
says he's seen enough of that in his
lifetime sociologists are already
referring to the demonstrators as
generation Ghazi they grew up under
prime minister at Owens government and
have profited from the economic
liberalisation of the country they are
more urban compared to their parents and
sickle characteristics they has been
brought up in a less authoritarian
families who folk coach [ __ ] wasn't
interested in politics until a few weeks
ago when the police started their brutal
crackdown on the protests in Taksim
Square then the German raised engineer
decided to put his expertise into
practice he started to film the
demonstrations from above using small
drone aircraft one of his drones was
shot down with rubber bullets by
security forces I this book you can
document everything you can see what was
happening where the protest was what the
protesters did that was the idea I
didn't want to harm anyone it was just
for my own archives I never thought the
police would act like that and shoot
them down
now he films the opposition forums every
evening thousands of locals meet in
parks across the city with the motto
every Park is gay Z Park festivities are
combined with political discussions one
issue at hand is whether they should
form a new political party a ski is in
the crowd she doesn't think a new party
would be a good idea we should keep
trying to convince other groups and
societies such as religious people and
to deconstruct the mutual prejudices we
have the overriding goal has to remain
bringing down the air21 government bond
agreement then he rejoins the forum she
doesn't want to miss anything in this
vital phase for her country